welcome to pft ot on yahoo sports peter
king mike florio some of the big stories
in the nfl and the final four is locked
in the chiefs were the only repeat from
last year in the final eight so
obviously they're the only repeat team
in the final four andy reid with one
super bowl appearance in his lengthy and
illustrious nfl coaching career peter
is this
andy reid's opportunity to finally punch
through to the super bowl and get a
victory
this is the best chance he's had i would
say because last year
he faced basically maybe the new england
patriots at their last gasp of offensive
greatness
um and you know that's a tough game to
win
it's especially a tough game to win if
you lose the coin flip in overtime your
defense stinks and you don't have a
chance to touch the ball in overtime
because we all know that if the new
england patriots lost the coin flip to
start overtime there's a very good
chance it would have been a kansas city
la super bowl rather than a new england
la super bowl be that as it may
this is andy reid's best shot because
now for the first time he feels like
he's got a really truly competitive
defense you know chris jones needs to
play in this game but he's got a really
competitive defense
and my feeling is the biggest thing
about this defense is that now he's got
a swiss army knife on defense who he can
trust to make plays all over the defense
it's tyron man matthew playing for the
first time
pain free in about five years you know
after two acls and a meniscus last year
tyron matthew finally is totally healthy
and playing like it
so what does this mean to andy reid's
legacy if he can get to the super bowl
for a second time and win his first one
ever after all these years as a head
coach
i think it cements his legacy uh and you
know mike
i i am one of these guys who believes
that post season is is important to your
career but it shouldn't mean everything
you know ted williams never won a world
series dan marino never won a super bowl
uh but i still think that they are among
the best to ever play their particular
game
so i wouldn't say that if andy reid
never wins a super bowl that he can't be
considered
in the all-time pantheon of coaches look
at all of the guys he has trained as
you know as coaches under him look at
all the big games he's won now he hasn't
won the biggest game we know that
and he won't be bill belichick in nfl
history without winning at least a
couple of super bowls he probably never
will anyway
but i think my point would be i think
sustained long-term greatness and
imagination as a coach
that's andy reid's calling card
yeah not having the super bowl win
is obviously a negative but the
sustained performance
and and the deep resume all those years
all those wins all those postseason
appearances he gets into canton the
question is does he get it on the first
try or some later try but i think he's
already in you get that super bowl and
you make it a no-brainer first ballot
entry for andy reid uh and we'll see if
he gets there he's got two more wins to
make it happen check out more pft ot on
yahoo sports videos throughout the nfl
post season we'll see you next time
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports